رياض
الصالحين
الاذكار
[Silence]
بمز الله
خيرا
يز يا ايها الذين امنوا اذا قيل لكم
تفسحوا في المجالس فافسحوا يفسح الله
لكم اسك
الله جنه
[Silence]
حديث انس بن مالك رضي الله
عنه مسن صلى الله عليه
وسلم parfor
[Silence]
حلق
الذكر الامام
الترمذي رحمه
الله
حديث ابو
هريره ابو سعيد الخدري رضي الله
عنهما م صلى الله عليه
وسلم
الله
are سكين
الله سبحانه
وتعالى الامام مسلم رحمه الله
تعالى
الحديث ابو هريره رضي الله
عنه صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله angs that
out the ro looking
people
when when they
find call
[Silence]
‏over
them
sk سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
وتعالى يسالونك الجنه
[Silence]
الله الله سبحان وتى
يجونك من النار الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله
[Silence]
‏the almighty says to the
angels be witness that have forgiven
them one of the angels speaks and
says there is a among them just passing
by الله then says i will gr him my foren
also
[Silence]
البخاري مسلم رحمهم الله
تعالى اللهم اجعلنا من
الذاكرين اللهم اغفر لنا وارحمنا وتب
علينا
وسامحنا ربنا بالصالحات اعمالنا امين
اللهم من اراد بالمسلمين سوء فاجعل دائره
السوء تدور عليه اللهم اغفر لنا وارحمنا
اللهم وثبت اقدامنا وانصرنا على القوم
الظالمين وانصرنا على القوم الكافرين بمدد
ونصر من عندك يا اكرم الاكرمين ويا ارحم
الراحمين اللهم اغفر لنا ما قدمنا وما
اخرنا وما اسررنا ما اعلنا وما انت اعلم
به منا اللهم ات انفسنا تقواها وزكها انت
خير من زكاها انت وليها ومولاها اللهم انا
نعوذ بك من علم لا ينفع ومن قلب لا يخشع
ومن عين لا تدمع ومن نفس لا تشبع ومن دعوه
لا يستجاب لها اللهم تقبل منا انك انت
السميع العليم وتب علينا يا مولانا انك
انت التواب الرحيم اللهم احقن دماء
المسلمين في كل مكان اللهم احقن دماء
المسلمين في كل مكان ووحد صفوفهم والف بين
قلوبهم برحمه ونصر ومدد من عندك يا ارحم
الراحمين اللهم اغفر لنا وارحمنا وتب
علينا وسامحنا اللهم واغفر لمن انشا هذا
المكان ومن عمل فيه لله من خير وبر واحسان
اللهم اغفر لاخينا من ساعدنا وفتح لنا هذا
المسجد المبارك وكل من يساعد فيه وكل من
شارك فيه برحمه منك يا ارحم الراحمين
اللهم اغفر وايد من يحترم العلماء ويجل
العلماء ويطلب البركه من العلماء اللهم
انك على ما تشاء قدير وبال الاجابه جدير
ان الله يامر بالعدل والاحسان وايتاء ذي
القربى وينهى عن الفحشاء والمنكر والبغي
يعظكم لعلكم
تذكرون واقم الصلاه يرحمك
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر